hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear going back to the 1960s on this one
so i want to say i guess like most
horror fans worthy of the name i suppose
i'm a big gigantic fan of vincent price
and i will watch pretty much
anything that he's in
uh the man was just a legend he
absolutely never phoned in a performance
he was always worth watching and he
always classed up whatever movie he was
in no matter how inexpensive the
production was i mean he was just like a
class act overall
i'm also
somewhat familiar with the works of
nathaniel hawthorne i read a couple of
his novels and several of his short
stories over the years i think even when
i was doing uh the witching hour i read
several of his short stories on there so
you know i'm kind of familiar with his
work not super familiar but you know a
little bit and as you guys know i love
love love horror anthologies there's
just something that's really really
appealing about horror anthologies to me
so you know that eventually i had to get
around to watching and reviewing a movie
that ticks all three of those boxes
which is 1963's twice told tales so this
movie was produced by a company called
admiral pictures
which looked like it was a pretty
short-lived company they didn't really
put out that many movies and it looks
like most of the movies they put out
were westerns at least going by the
titles um though i will note that they
had released a psychological horror
movie called diary of a madman which
also had vincent price in it which came
out in 1962 which is actually on my list
because i want to see it i've heard it's
pretty good like i said it's like kind
of a psycho rip off but i've heard that
it's a really good one
so twice told tales and we were talking
about today was actually arrest directed
by uh sydney salcow whose resume goes
all the way back to i think 1936 or
something like that
and he would actually go on to work with
vincent price again in 1964 with the
last man on earth which of course was
the adaptation of richard matheson's i'm
legend which we reviewed not too long
ago so it seems like the idea to do an
anthology film based on classic stories
came mostly from the success of roger
corman's edgar allan poe adaptations
obviously which were really successful
now at this point all all of them hadn't
come out yet but there had been house of
usher had come out in 1960 uh pitt and
the pendulum came out in 1961 and tales
of terror which was an edgar allen poe
anthology film uh it came out in 1962.
all of those also had vincent price in
them because he was just everywhere uh
since american international pictures
and roger corman and everything seem to
kind of have a corner on the market of
edgar allen poe's stories and they
didn't really want to repeat it admiral
chose to do something a little bit
different so they're like well we're
gonna mine you know the works of another
american dark romantic writer like in
the same vein like of the 19th century
who is nathaniel hawthorne and i kind of
feel like probably nowadays he's best
known for his 1850 novel the scarlet
letter which i don't know if they're
probably still reading it at school i
read it in high school i actually quite
liked uh the book um but you know i know
a lot of high school students don't like
it but i actually quite liked it i read
it in 10th grade i think now hawthorne
did actually publish a short story
collection which was called twice told
tales in 1837. uh the reason it was
called twice told tales was because it
was all stories that had appeared like
in other publications prior like in
magazines and newspapers and stuff um
but interestingly only one of the
stories that was adapted for this movie
uh dr heidegger's experiment uh was in
that anthology the second story which is
uh rappuccini's daughter was actually
you know published again in various
periodicals but then it was collected in
the 1846 book which was called mosses
from an old mance and then the third one
the house of seven gables was actually a
very loose adaptation of of course the
standalone novel which came out in 1851
now while the movie twice told tales i
think it does suffer a little bit from
its you know clearly very low budget
i think it's slightly too long um clocks
in right about two hours and i think
probably maybe 15 20 minutes could have
been trimmed out of there it's not a big
deal but you know
and they did take some liberties with
the source material and i kind of have
mixed feelings about that but it's still
a pretty solid watch i mean vincent
price is in it and he's in all three of
the things like playing a different role
but he's always a villain and it's
always like fun to watch him be a
villain and also has some very welcome
appearances by some other great actors
like sebastian cabot and beverly garland
who i absolutely love she worked with
roger corman a lot as well
also turning up for all you mst fans out
there beverly garland was actually in a
lot of movies that were on mystery side
theater as well but also turning up in a
significant role is brett halsey now he
had been in a [ __ ] ton of movies like he
was in a lot of westerns and things like
that like going back to i think the
1940s maybe um or maybe just the 50s i
can't remember but i immediately
recognized him as bix dugan aka big
stupid
from the girl in lover's lane from 1960
which was actually one of the more
decent movies that was appeared on
mystery science theater 3000. um i
actually think that was a pretty good
movie they did as well uh halsey was
also in this is very interesting uh
several later luchio fulchi films
including demonia and a cat in the brain
like the late 80s early 90s folcie like
you know not too long before he died so
you know it really is kind of a small
horror world after all isn't it so the
first story which is dr heidegger's
experiment uh sees two old coots uh one
of whom is named carl this is dr
heidegger of the title and that's played
by sebastian cabot and alex who's played
by vincent price they're kind of like
meeting at carl's house during a really
bad thunderstorm to celebrate carl's
79th birthday
now we learned that 38 years prior uh
carl's fiancee sylvia
died on the eve of their wedding and
carl has never really gotten over it he
keeps a very badly done portrait of her
like above the fireplace and has never
even touched another woman in all the
years since which
okay uh even creepier than that though
uh he also has a crypt right outside the
house like he can see it like from the
window that has her body in it and it
also has an empty coffin in there like
all ready for him when he inevitably
like pops his clogs so
healthy not really but you know what i
mean he's not hurting anybody so
whatever so the storm or perhaps some
kind of supernatural force that's not
really made clear actually causes the
crypt door to sort of like blast off
like kind of fall off which it's never
done obviously in the 38 years since it
was put there and carl goes over to
investigate the damage taking a very
reluctant alex with him
in the crypt they find out that sylvia's
coffin has kind of like slid off the
platform that it was on but as they're
trying to put it back on there the lid
comes off and there's sylvia's dead body
but it looks fresh as a daisy even
though you think after 38 years she
would just be like you know a crumbly
old skeleton at this point so carl who i
think is who's like a scientist uh he
deduces that the water that's been
dripping down into the coffin from the
spring above the vault has maybe like
restorative powers and tests this by
bringing he kind of brings some of the
water back to the house and then he has
this old like smushed like pressed rose
that he had like that sylvia gave him 38
years ago and he's kept it pressed in a
book so he puts the water on it and it
pops back to life as if it's alive again
so after that he's like well [ __ ] what
would happen if i drank this so he
drinks some of the elixir and becomes
youngish again like you know maybe in
his 30s or something like that whereas
before he was 79 years old and he's you
know overjoyed obviously we found like
the fountain of youth uh now he and alex
will be able to have another whole
entire lifetime of their awesome
friendship alex also drinks some of the
water after he sees that it didn't kill
his friend uh and turns back into foxy
younger vincent price because obviously
they put like old makeup on which is
actually pretty good now that i'm like
thinking about it
now they're both pretty jazzed about
this situation as you would be
but then carl remembers that even if he
gets to live a whole other lifetime um
and actually maybe could be immortal
because he's like that you know that
spring has been running there for like
38 years so why should it stop now we
can just go drink more if we start
getting old again um but he still
doesn't have his true love his one true
love sylvia by his side but he thinks
what if the water doesn't just restore
youth what if
you could also bring somebody back from
the dead so yeah you know how this is
going to go down uh they spoiler alert
resurrects sylvia after 38 years in her
grave uh she's actually pretty cool with
it uh takes the whole thing in stride
after they explained her and she's just
kind of like oh okay uh and she just
goes along with it which i thought was
kind of funny even though i mean like
the last thing she remembers obviously
was you know it was the eve of her
wedding and she's like oh i don't feel
too good i'm gonna go lay down and then
obviously she died
so that's like the last thing she
remembers she still thinks it was 38
years ago now anyone with any knowledge
of at all of uh horror tropes will
pretty much see where this story is
going from like a mile away you know
because there's going to be all kind of
like double crossing and shit's not
sylvia's not the person you thought she
was and all this other kind of stuff
like i said i figured it out but that
didn't really like dampen my enjoyment
of it and i think this was actually my
favorite of the three adapted tales i
will note however if you guys used to
listen to my witching hour i believe i
did actually read this original story
like on that series um so i will note
that it is very very different from the
original hawthorne story
what happens in that is that old dr
heidegger has received some kind of a
magical like fountain of youth water
from florida or so he says and he gives
it to three of his friends who are like
two men and a woman uh as an experiment
now the trio become young again but then
a bunch of like kind of long forgotten
jealousy and resentment concerning this
old love triangle that they had going on
uh starts rearing its head they have
like a big brawl or some kind of like
fight or something like that and the
flask that holds like the last of the
water gets broken and the three of them
kind of revert back to their elderly
selves now it's been a while since i
read it but i was of the impression
that the water
never did actually make the three people
young i interpreted it as dr heidegger's
experiment being maybe testing whether
he could make them think they had grown
young like through the power of
suggestion so i thought it wasn't even
so much that the water was magical i
thought that he was seeing if he could
make them believe it and could make them
see themselves as young even though they
actually weren't but i could be totally
pulling that out of my ass but that was
just the impression that i got when i
read the story if you've read it like
tell me if you think that if you got
that impression too because that's what
i thought it was but i don't know it's
kind of left ambiguous um but in the
original story anyway you know nobody
gets brought back from the dead and
nobody gets killed so i kind of
appreciate like i said and this was was
what i meant when i said i kind of have
mixed feelings about like the liberties
they took with the source material in
this case
i don't think that just a straight
adaptation of the original story would
have been all that scary because the
story isn't scary it's not like a scary
story it's more like i don't know if i'd
say it was like funny but it's just kind
of like poignant maybe um so it's not
actually really a horror story so i kind
of like that they just took the germ of
the story with the magical water and
like making them young again and stuff
like that and then try to like horror it
up some because they were obviously
trying to make this a horror movie like
in the vein of the edgar allen poe ones
now the second story rappuccini's
daughter is actually the most faithful
to the original nathaniel hawthorne
story so it's set sometime in the 16th
century in padua italy
and you got sinister ass vincent price
playing giacomo rappochini who's a
scientist of some kind in the story i
think he's a botanist which i'm assuming
he is in this as well although i don't
think they say that and he has this kind
of like real lush garden outside his
villa and it has you know lots and lots
of plants but then it has this one
particular plant that's like really or
it's like a bush or something um that's
kind of like really weird looking and
it's super super poisonous and it has
like all these like spiky purple blooms
on it and it seems to kill
anything that touches it whether human
or butterfly or caterpillar or whatever
the hell
now giacomo has this gorgeous but
mysterious daughter named beatrice who
never re leaves the confines of the
villa or the grounds and has never been
seen by the townsfolk they all know she
lives there but nobody's ever seen her
next door to the rappuccinis however uh
there's this young student named
giovanni who's played by the guy from
the girl in lovers lane
now he's renting a room like he's a
university student and his window
happens to overlook the garden
so he sees beatrice one day and is
immediately smitten with her but she is
like super reluctant to get to know him
and she basically warns like look you
never ever come down to this garden it
you know it's gonna end badly now they
do carry on kind of a bit of a
friendship they don't only show this but
it's kind of implied where she's down in
the garden and he's up in the window and
they have like these long conversations
and stuff but giovanni is starting to
like i said essentially like fall in
love with her and he's starting to get
curious as to why she's kind of keeping
him at arm's length and won't let him
come down to see her so one day he
essentially muscles his way into the
garden uh much to beatrice's horror so
giovanni is just kind of like hey what
gives like i thought we were friends or
i thought we were you know having a
thing or whatever so she tries to
explain to him what the deal is
she's like okay well you know how my dad
is a crazy person all right so nutty
professor dad played by vincent price
has essentially been harvesting the
deadly kind of radioactive toxin from
the weird purple plant in the garden for
decades
and or however old she is and infusing
her blood with it basically making her
touch poisonous to any living thing like
any person or animal
he started doing this she says
after her mom ran off with another man
when beatrice was just a baby so the dad
was a little bitter about it and he says
well by making the daughter like unable
to ever touch another man without
killing him i will be able to
essentially save her from ever sinning
like her mother and keeping her pure and
also this isn't stated outright but
imply that it's like she'll never leave
me which is a little bit weird okay
giovanni obviously doesn't uh believe
this at first uh and neither would you
if somebody said hey i got a poison
touch you know what i mean uh but
beatrice actually demonstrates by
touching a lizard and essentially like
cooking it alive like right in front of
his face
so she begs giovanni please just forget
about me we can never be together um you
know i can't touch you or i'll kill you
now giovanni loves her so much that he
goes and consults another scientist at
the university to see if he can come up
with an antidote
meanwhile giacomo the dad while at first
predictably discouraging the
relationship between giovanni and his
daughter because like i said he just
wants to make it so like she can't never
touch another man because of the because
of you know the hoe that the mom was i
guess he later seems to have a change of
heart
and claims that he has a way for them to
be together and it's okay for them to
get married uh-oh like i said because
he's a villain so you know this is gonna
that's not gonna be a good situation
uh this story was pretty good too
although i kind of wish that the
filmmakers had made it a bit creepier i
really do love the idea of this kind of
like affinity between this poisonous
plant and the poisonous woman i thought
that was like really cool and like i
said that's directly from the story this
is very very similar to the original
story but some of the horror i think was
kind of undercut by having almost all of
the action take place in the daytime the
garden set was actually like cool but it
would have been a lot eerier
i think like in the dark so i kind of
wish there'd been more stuff going on at
night but oh well what are you gonna do
um as i mentioned this segment is almost
in almost exact retelling of the
original story so if you've read that um
you'll know how it ends up uh badly in
case you couldn't guess now the third
segment uh probably deviates the most
from its source material now i read the
novel the house of the seven gables many
years ago and while i liked it it wasn't
as horry i guess as this adaptation made
it seem which is kind of like what's
going on with a lot of these like i said
i feel like they were trying to make it
more
horror
to compete with the po pictures but a
lot of nathaniel hawthorne stories
aren't overtly horror you know what i'm
saying
uh so while the movie like while this
adaptation keeps the core elements of
the book intact you got like the long
rivalry between the pension and the mall
families you got the search for the
missing papers the land deed or whatever
you have the accusation of witchcraft
and the subsequent curse placed on the
males of the pension line by matthew
mall
the rest of it was pretty different and
exaggerated most of the characters and
plot threads from the novel were either
taken out or were like changed around i
guess that was probably like the best
route to go in this situation um as the
novel is like pretty long and complex
and has like a lot of historical
backstory and all this other kind of
stuff which obviously you couldn't cram
into it because this segment of the
movie is only 45 minutes long
fun fact vincent price also starred in
another adaptation of the house of the
seven gables back in 1940 which is
actually a lot more faithful to the
source material although it also took a
lot of liberties i don't know i haven't
seen that many adaptations of house of
the seven gables but most of them
usually do take some artistic license
with the story because like i said the
story as it's written it's a good book
but it's not real cinematic you know
what i mean so in this truncated version
that's in twice told tales vincent plays
a guy named gerald pinchen uh who is
actually not a character in the original
novel and he's kind of like this
scheming a-hole who comes back to the
titular house of the seven gables after
17 years away i believe that they don't
i don't think they actually like explain
why he's been gone for that long but i
think in the book maybe his equivalent
in the book was like in prison i don't
know it's like it said it's been a long
time since i've read it now his sister
hannah who is also not a character in
the novel although there is a woman in
there named hebsibo who i think is kind
of like the equivalent
she's lived in the house the entire time
and she's not real happy that her
conniving brother has come back to the
homestead after all this time especially
after it seems that he mostly bankrupted
the family it was like a gambler or
something like that now the house
supposedly contains a vault which has
this valuable property deed in it
that will make gerald and hannah who are
the only two remaining pensions rich
again
but generations of the pension family
have been looking for this damn thing
for
you know ages and haven't been able to
find it now by the way 150 years ago the
pension family [ __ ] over the maul
family accusing a man named matthew mall
of witchcraft and getting him executed
so they could take his land this part is
pretty much right from the book the very
land in fact where the house of the
seven gables now stands now matthew
placed a curse on all the male
descendants of the pension line uh
ensuring they will all die in the movie
it was with blood on their lips in a
particular chair in the house i think in
the book if i remember correctly the
curse was god will give them blood to
drink i think was what uh he said
so this curse has been 100 effective so
far but gerald who is the last male
pension is certain he can buff the trend
and what's more he thinks that he has an
angle on how he can locate the vault
after all this time during the course of
this plan he contacts jonathan maul who
is a descendant of the rival family he's
trying to make peace and hoping he can
trade the house he's like i will give
you the house if you tell me where the
vault is
see what happened was that the house
itself was actually built by the brother
of the executed matthew mall like you
know whenever like a long time ago who
was the only architect in town and
because he was justifiably uh pissed off
at the pension family for getting his
brother executed he was like yeah i'll
build your house but i'm gonna hide this
vault where you [ __ ] heels we'll never
be able to find it so there um also put
the crypt matthew malls crypt like in
the basement which again was a little
[ __ ] you to the family that he hated so
much
so
vincent gerald's plan seems to be moving
along but
difficulties soon start to manifest
themselves
i neglected to mention that gerald has
brought along his wife alice played by
the lovely beverly garland uh this is
also not a character from the novel who
immediately when she comes to the house
she starts experiencing kind of like
paranormal phenomena like doors opening
by themselves
hearing her name called or hearing
someone else's name called which you
know get into there's kind of cold spots
knowing things about the past that she
has absolutely no way of knowing
now when jonathan maul arrives at the
house like after gerald calls him she
seems to already know him even though
she's never met him before and it's
implied that the long dead matthew mall
is actually trying to communicate with
her like paranormally through jonathan
who is his descendant now it's been a
long time since i read the novel
you know admittedly but i don't think
any of that was in the book um and i
have to say to you that the resolution
of the story in the movie
is a lot different than the ending of
the novel which as far as i remember was
like kind of a happy ending this does
absolutely not have a happy ending not
well not really i mean it's kind of
happy for a few people involved but you
know what i mean it's kind of [ __ ] up
too so this was also a pretty
entertaining story although as i said
it's wildly different from the source
material and like the first segment dr
heidegger's experiment the changes made
were almost all in service of making the
stories more horrific which i find i
can't really complain all that much
about i mean some of hawthorne's stories
were ghost stories absolutely but most
of them weren't really kind of like all
out horror in the way that like edgar
allan poe's stories were so you can see
why the filmmakers want to try to
increase the scare factor i guess like
in this anthology by adding a bunch of
elements that weren't in the original
stories i didn't really mind that but
i'm just gonna say like just a pro tip
please don't watch this movie instead of
reading the stories like if you have to
write an essay for your english class or
something like that because you will
absolutely absolutely get an f now if
you're into vincent price and like who
isn't really uh and you like classic
american literature and you like
anthology horror movies you will
probably dig this one um it's not as
good as corman's po cycle movies it's a
little bit slow in places like i said
they probably could have trimmed out
like 15 20 minutes without like losing
too much like you know kind of up the
pacing a little bit but all in all um i
actually found it pretty engaging and
fun and i mean
i'm not gonna lie like price is always
just a joy to watch especially when he's
playing bad guys which he is in three
different roles in this one so you know
you get three vincent's for the price of
one and i'm not gonna complain too much
about that either so that will do it for
this flickers of fear and i will see you
guys on the next one
bye